so it's absolutely crazy to think that
if if it wasn't for that minor detail I
would not have gotten this job at all
[Music]
heads up guys my name is the chana
welcome back to the couch of relaxing
conversations for another storytime with
China today I thought that I would tell
you this story of how I got my first job
in the games industry and what was
pretty much my first full-time job my
first real job in general and this video
is really gonna be a good sequel or I
guess technically a prequel to the last
video I made which is why I left that
job so we all know how the prequels are
so to get the full picture of how I got
this job in the first place we kind of
have to go back to the beginning of my
time at university so the year was 2014
that's wrong so the year was 2013 I just
finished high school the year before and
I had decided to do a software
engineering degree at a university and
this was the first year of me actually
starting that degree at this point I
basically had decided that I wanted to
work in the games industry I was a lot
more interested in the actual software
engineering kind of programming aspect
of that I didn't want to do any kind of
games degree because I knew that from
what I had seen in open days those were
a lot more about like how to use unity
there were essentially all inclusive
kind of courses where you did like a
little bit of programming like 3d
modeling aren't related stuff game
design I wasn't really interested in any
of that I was interested specifically in
the technology and I guess the technical
aspects behind games so I figured that
doing a software engineering degree and
then maybe like specializing or majoring
in some sort of games related thing
would be a better way to go because that
was more or less the kind of stuff that
I was interested in learning and the job
that I essentially wanted so I started
the software engineering degree at the
beginning of 2013 so you can study the
course and then the year before your
last provided that you had good enough
grades you could choose to do either
like a six month or a 12 month industry
placement basically like you could go
and work for a company in the industry
that you were studying in
for six or twelve months and most of
them were around twelve months or a year
and then the following year you'd come
back to university and complete that
final year and then graduate and in a
lot of these cases because you had
already spent time working at a company
for like a year you could potentially
get hired back by that company since
you've already got experience with them
and provided you do a good job of course
they would want to offer you a full-time
position and that year of work
experience would be like completely paid
and everything and I just thought that
like that to me was so attractive
because even though I guess technically
prolongs your caused by a year the fact
that you actually get real-world
experience and you can put that on your
resume as like one year of work
experience that to me was so much more
valuable than just going to university
completing a degree and then you know
trying to find a job with no experience
because of course everyone wants to hire
someone with experience so a quick recap
I was doing a four year degree and then
what would happen is the fourth year of
that degree I wouldn't be doing the
degree I would do the work experience
that was my plan and then I'd come back
on the fifth year to finish my degree
and everything was looking good however
about halfway through that first
semester me and a couple of friends that
I had made were basically seeing that
what that specific course was and
because it was like specifically like a
Bachelor of engineering I think software
engineering being like the major because
it was a Bachelor of engineering part of
the course was the fact that it would
actually give you an engineering license
and in order to make that happen they
obviously had to have to teach you
engineering in general and so that first
year was mostly made up of engineering
units there was some introduction like
to programming unit but a lot of the
units or subjects and this university
they were called units a lot of the
units there were to do with engineering
nothing to do with programming
whatsoever so for example in that first
semester I had done like an engineering
maths unit I had done a like electronic
systems unit and that electronic systems
unit was basically all about like
drawing circuit diagrams like putting
resistors down trying to do the math to
figure out like how much of everything
you'd need drawing PCBs I mean there
were some fun parts to that that I
enjoyed like the practical things when
we got like the soldiering irons out and
we actually built stuff that was fun but
for the most part sitting in a classroom
during circuit diagrams or
doing PCB designs in some PCB software
on the computer that was just not really
at all related to what I wanted to do
and it's also important to remember that
because of all of this I was also going
to be at uni for an extra year and then
I also have to pay for that extra year
and so me and these friends decided that
this was not something we wanted to do
maybe we can change into a degree that
is a little bit more in line with what
we care about and what we want to do
which is like programming and so we
found this other degree to this
University offered which was like a
Bachelor of Science professional
software development being I guess the
major I'm not sure like if it was
specifically the major or if it like a
narrow focus anyway
and this degree was a three year degree
so it was one year less which that's
important to note by the way the fact
that that one was a four year and a
three year degree remember that because
we're gonna come back to that and so
everything was approved and we were all
able to switch into this new degree but
there was a bit of a caveat and that was
the fact that some of the subjects that
we had done were not exactly the same
obviously as the first year subjects of
that other degree and specifically some
of them were able to be carried across
so the engineering maths degree that I
did I was able to basically get that
credited towards another Univ study
which was in the new degree which was I
think it was called like I don't know
some really basic math thing about like
bullying's and like truth tables and
just like completely just easy stuff
that everyone knew without actually even
having to study it but I remember even
that was like a bit of a fight like I
had to be like look engineering maths
like clearly way more advanced yes it
didn't cover truth tables but come on
like everyone knows what that is please
credit me towards this unit and finally
they agreed but the electronic systems
degree which was about PCBs and like
circuit diagrams and resistors and all
of that stuff I couldn't get that
transferred at all into the new degree
so because of that I withdrew from that
subject I still finished my engineering
maths and all the other units which were
basically I think the same in both of
these degrees and I ended that first
semester having completed three units
instead of four because I would drew
from electronic systems I didn't need it
that's also an important detail so long
story short second half of 2013 was
great I was in this new to curry I loved
it my friends loved it we did like some
like various programming subjects there
were still some things that weren't like
the most fun things in the world but we
weren't really doing engineering
specifically anymore like we weren't
doing I think engineering maths B or the
second part of that which would have
been in that semester it was more in
line with what we were doing and we were
happy because we'd basically be
finishing a year earlier we wouldn't get
the engineering license but we didn't
really want that or care about that it
was great so then in comes 2014 and that
was the second year I guess of these of
this three year degree now because this
was now a three year degree that work
experience year gets pushed up a year it
gets brought forward so instead of it
being the fourth year and then the 50
I'll come back and finish uni it was the
third year now and then the fourth year
I'd come back and finished so in other
words it would have been in 2015 the
year summer of grade actually moved
moved out of my parents place that year
I just turned 19 I was living in an
apartment I was actually work wise I was
making videos for machinima and that's
how I was basically paying the bills I'm
sure a lot of you don't even know about
that but in 2014 I think it doesn't 13
even I made a series called lapses for
machinima drama was like a little
minecraft machinima fortunately all that
stuff is gone because machinima doesn't
exist anymore that was quite a cool
little series had like millions of views
it was really fun to produce then later
I made some call duty videos for
missionary spawn anyway good times is
all I can say from that the first
semester of uni was really enjoyable I
think I did like a daughter structures
and patterns you know which was about
C++ that was my first real exposure to
C++ and I loved it I was doing a lot of
programming in my spare time as well and
because of that because I was trying to
build games and you know do all this
stuff one of my lecturers ended up
pointing me towards another kind of
lecturer in the university who is
essentially in charge of Alder like game
related units and just in general in
charge of game dev related stuff at this
university and me and him ended up
becoming pretty good friends like we'd
go out to lunch together
I'd constantly come to his office like
probably once every week at least just
to show him what I was working on get
his advice on things because this was
someone obviously who was a lot more
qualified and had a lot more experience
than me and just being able to basically
have a mentor like that and you know
talk about all this stuff I was
hang-on was really cool because i was
doing a lot of stuff in my spare time
and i was trying to learn as much as
possible that was really important I
think the fact that I had that kind of
friendship with him that was really
important to me getting a job because
what happened after that is I went to
Europe during like the winter holidays
he s like June July and so after I
returned from Europe it was really time
to start applying to all of these
different jobs and I remember the first
thing that happened was literally that
first week at uni that was back he
called me into his office and he was
like look not really supposed to be
telling you this but one of the
companies who wants to take in students
for next year is EI and they have a
studio here in Melbourne and they want
three interns and I think you'd be
really good for that position and I was
like wow that's pretty cool because
first of all that rate I think the
companies you usually what would happen
is these companies would basically
contact this university or the
university will contact them and be like
hey we have students do you want them or
they'd be like we want some interns and
then they'd be like this long list of
companies and then you know I think in a
few weeks a few weeks into that semester
you'd start applying to all these
companies with like your resume and your
cover letter and all that stuff and this
was like a few weeks even prior to that
so I already kind of had a heads up and
I was like cool this sounds like exactly
what I would want and then when the kind
of the list of companies came out and
they were probably like 10 to 20
companies on that list so there were
quite a few when that came out I saw
very quickly that this whole like ei
situation was by far just the best thing
out of all of that and the reason was
they were about 20 companies a lot of
them had nothing to do with games and in
fact I think EA was the only games
company on that list but furthermore
there was only one company I think that
was actually in the city EA was kind of
on the outskirts of the city I live
close to the city and then a lot of the
other companies most of them all of them
really were were like a 40-minute to one
hour drive from me and when I looked up
the address for this for this EA studio
it was it was literally walking distance
from my place so there was one place
that was kind of in the city which would
have been about maybe like a half an
hour commute there was EA which was like
walking distance from my place
walking distance I mean about a half an
hour walk so not like completely close
but still about a half an hour walk and
when I started working there I ended up
riding my skateboard a lot of the times
to work which is like 15 to 20 minutes
away so it was just in a really good
location and when I saw it that and when
I realized just how close it was to my
place and how great that would be
compared to like a 40 to 60 minute drive
just way out of the city to try and get
to these companies I was like I need
this job
like I absolutely I don't even want to
apply anywhere else and in fact I don't
think I did apply anywhere else which
was like clearly obviously not the right
thing to do but I was just so set on
this that I was like I could not imagine
working anywhere else you know I think
one of the companies was like Zendesk
which is like kind of like a a helpdesk
like online web app slash web site a few
of the other ones were to do with like
school systems or like and some kind of
engineering work maybe the point is none
of it was games related a lot of it
sounded really boring and I mean uh like
obviously I would have still done it
because I would need programming
experience and I'm sure it wouldn't be
as bad as it sounds but for me at that
point in time I was like you know what
if this does not work out I'm just gonna
do I'm just gonna keep doing YouTube and
finish my degree I don't want to work
anymore anywhere else I need this
specific job and so of course I applied
I wrote my resume we had a unit I think
based on teaching us how to do that and
then I also wrote a cover letter I
emailed that to like the the kind of
work experience department in this
university who'd then emailed it to AAA
and I think two hours later I got a
direct email from AAA being like hey
like you know we've we've read your
resume and in my resume I had like my
youtube channel and the fact that I was
obviously interested in programming and
I was kind of teaching that and doing
all that stuff and in my cover letter I
explained as well what I what I like
doing and how I was really interested in
like building game engines and all of
this stuff and so I got the email back
from EA about two hours later and they
were like you know we want to have an
interview like as soon as possible and
also we have an event coming up that's
kind of like a little bit exclusive that
was like in someplace in that like the I
think the 50th floor of some building in
the city you know come along to that as
well if you're interested and so I was I
was like wow this is incredible
well you know let's have an interview
like I don't know we set up an interview
like three days later but there was one
problem and there was one complication
and that is the fact that I technically
didn't qualify for this work experience
based on this University's criteria and
the reason for that was as I mentioned
before I had switched degrees and I had
done three units of study in that first
semester of my first year instead of
four and one of the requirements for
this work experience program I think you
needed like a credit average and mine
was quite a bit above that and then you
also needed to have completed 12 units
now this was semester two in my second
year so I'd done three semesters which
if you did full semesters that would
have been 4 times 3 which is 12 units
that would have been perfect but I
hadn't done one unit because I couldn't
I mean I switched degrees and it was
just it was it was not relevant so I had
11 units and I needed 12 and so the
university I think ended up sending me
an email being like actually I'm sorry
you don't qualify for this and I was
like that's that's insane like this is
this is perfect they want to interview
me this is great and so I went to my gay
like head of game development friend and
I was like this is you know this sucks
can you do anything about this and he
was like let me see what I can do I'll
make a call then the next day I get a
phone call being like it's all good I
straightened it out you're good to go
and I was like thank you and so I had
that interview I think the next day a TA
and I was that was in like October 2014
so I was I was 19 which is pretty pretty
crazy to think about and I was basically
I had like a 15 minute interview with HR
and they just asked me about like where
I see myself in five years you know what
kind of person I am what my hobbies are
all that stuff and then came the
technical director of the whole studio
along with his like righthand and I'm
just looking at this right hold on let
me this is why it's better to close all
of your windows and film in a completely
controlled lighting environment because
anyway whatever and they gave me like a
two-hour technical interview like it
went on for sir
maybe was like an hour and a half I
think maybe the full interview with HR
was like two hours or something like
that but for an hour and a half we bait
they asked me so many questions about
various data structures about like you
know shaders in OpenGL and like about
graphics programming and a lot of the
stuff that I I guess it claimed to have
done in my videos or in my cover letter
or in one way or another it was I mean I
I definitely didn't answer a lot of
their questions correctly but I guess
they were more interested in my kind of
line of thinking and how I thought
through these problems even if I didn't
know and of course they revealed later
they would have just kept going until I
basically had said that there's no way
that I knew any of this because the
point was for me to festival not pretend
that I knew stuff that I didn't and just
admit to not knowing something but also
have a go at actually solving the
problem to the best of my ability which
of course is it's pretty standard for an
interview although I don't think I
I probably didn't know that at the time
and then I remembered the last kind of
half hour of that was damn being like
alright what do you want to know about
us and I had so many questions I mean I
had done a bit of research on the studio
I saw some of the games they made I
asked them a bunch of questions about
that I asked them what it was like to
work there what their favorite things to
work on were you know all of that stuff
we just chatted for half an hour and I
remember we would be sitting there in
silence and I'd be like you know I
almost I was like trying to think of
something to say because I was like I
don't want them to leave now like this
is a great conversation and I felt like
leading up to the interview I was quite
nervous but then as soon as I sat down I
was just like well this is fun this is
fun you know I'm gonna try and enjoy
this and I wasn't nervous at all during
the interview and I'm like that a lot
generally leading up to an event or
leading up to something I'll be quite
nervous but then when it's actually
happening you know it's it's totally
fine I play music a lot and it's pretty
much the same as what I'm getting ready
for a performance or something like that
it's like it's quiet it's quite
nerve-wracking but then when you're
actually up there on stage performing
it's totally fine and I mean it's the
same here you've just got to actually
take in the moment and enjoy it to the
max because soon it's gonna be over and
then you'll be like why didn't I enjoy
myself more and I think that's excellent
advice for an interview because it's a
lot of fun to actually be in a situation
like that and also
quite a unique experience that you of
course don't get every day and so long
story short after that technical
interview I again had some time with HR
they asked me how it went and it was
just great and I think that was on like
the Friday and then the event they had
invited me to was on the following
Thursday and I actually ended up seeing
the technical director of like that
studio who had done the interview with
me along with my friend from the front
like the head of games development stuff
at my university he was there as well at
the event we ended up kind of being in a
circle talking and and he asked him kind
of in front of me so I had the interview
with younger and it was like well I
approved him so it's you know I guess HR
and all that stuff and then the
following day I remember getting a phone
call while I was like Nicole was
volunteering at the help desk at the
programming help desk at University as
cheesy as that might sound but I
remember getting a phone call and they
were like it was from it was HR from the
EA studio and they were like hey you
know just wanted to say that uh you know
we loved you and we want to offer you a
contract so we're going to send that
over and the technical director did that
interviewed you actually wants you on
his team which is like a game engine
team so we'll put you on that first
we'll see how that goes in there you
know maybe we'll move you around and
we'll kind of find a place for you but
ultimately like congratulations will
email you the contract and yeah so that
was I remember that was quite an amazing
feeling I was particularly excited that
I was not only working at this studio
but I was working on the technical
directors team because I knew that well
he worked on the game engine team and
his team was in charge of building the
game engine that this studio used for
all of their games so I was super
excited about that and yeah and I think
that the thing that always gets me with
this is that if I had not changed
degrees if I had stayed in that software
engineering degree then I would never
have gone this internship because this
internship was taking place during it
was during 2015 but if I had done a
four-year degree instead of a three-year
degree my work experience here would
have been 2016 and with
that internship specifically so ei
wanted three interns they ended up
hiring two they wanted and and one of
them I think later became a designer or
something like it wasn't even didn't
even stay as a software engineer so they
basically got just me as a software
engineer out of that and then it since
then I think they have never done a
software engineering internship I think
four years down the road or three years
down the road they did like a game
design internship or something but
especially this core technology team
never had done an internship after that
and ei that es you do as a hauled into
an internship so it's absolutely crazy
to think that if if it wasn't for that
minor detail I would not have gotten
this job at all and of course not only
that but the fact that I was friends
with that lecturer and he knew me and he
knew I was good for this job he was able
to make that phone call to kind of
rewrite the rules of this university had
and actually get me accepted as well and
I think that's like really kind of
humbling to think about the fact that
that it's you know literally like the
Stars just had to align to make this
happen and I'm so thankful for that and
that internship was absolutely fantastic
within like my first day at that
internship and I might make a video
talking about what what working at EA
and specifically what that internship
experience was like few guys interested
leave a comment below that felt like day
one I had already pushed code to like
the master branch of their code
repository and I think within two weeks
I was like in charge of developing like
the level editor and adding new features
and stuff so in terms of how they
treated me in that actual internship
experience it was absolutely amazing and
I talked a little bit about like how
much I enjoyed working at EA and how
good that experience was in my while at
EA video I know a lot of comments said
that they thought I was like lying or
just painting EA in a good light I'm not
sure exactly why I would do that I don't
work for them anymore they're definitely
not paying me anything but I do want to
mention that of course I live in
Australia in Melbourne and I'm sure that
the experience of working for AAA in
Melbourne is very different from working
for EA in the US because well first of
all we have different laws we have
different like
we have different employee and
employment laws so that's gonna make a
big difference and then also in general
the Australian culture is completely
different from the US so again my
experience was fantastic and I would I
would work there again for sure but you
know if you don't like to experience in
the US then that's cool so just keep
that in mind I'm specifically talking
about ei in Australia anyway hope you
guys enjoyed this story time with Jonah
if you did please do not forget to hit
that like button it really helps the
channel out thank you all for watching I
will see you next time on this couch of
relaxing conversations with another
story goodbye
[Music]